one-fifth of seafood is thought to be
caught illegally or is simply unreported
if you can't see it you can't manage it
and I know from experience you can't
monitor the whole ocean from the decks
of ships using GPS location data Global
fishing watch built the first ever
livestream map to monitor the industrial
fishing fleet when we were working with
our partners in Japan and South Korea
they told us there was illegal fishing
suspected in North Korean Waters but
when we first took a look on our map we
could see very little fishing because
those vessels were not sharing their GPS
location data as they should we call
them dark vessels and generally dark
vessels are up to no good so we had to
turn to other sources of data we looked
at satellite-based radar and Optical
imagery and we lit that region up we
revealed an armada of almost a thousand
vessels the techniques we use to
illuminate what was happening in North
Korea we can use anywhere
and everywhere to make the invisible
visible we can end pirate fishing and we
can transform motion management for the
common good of all